[Music]
christina fernandez de kirchner was
greeting supporters outside her home in
argentina when she was confronted with a
gun held to her face
the vice president ducked witnesses
screaming
kirchner was returning from court when
the ordeal happened the former president
is a divisive figure in argentina and is
in the midst of a corruption trial she
denies the charges
this is the most serious event we have
gone through since argentina returned to
democracy christina remains alive
because of a reason that has yet to be
confirmed technically the weapon that
had five bullets did not fire despite
being triggered
the man holding the gun was grabbed by
some of her supporters and detained he
is believed to be a brazilian in support
of the far right uh one of the media
organizations without confirmation says
that he had swastika uh in a tattoo in
his arm and he's also a light many far
right websites including something
called the demoniac
evil communism and things like that
in 2018 brazil's current president jared
bolsonaro was stabbed during an election
rally which boosted his popularity
something analysts say could happen now
for kirchner
the video shows very clearly a gun
against her head and that's the shock in
argentina society is so huge that that
might help her ironically to regain some
of the popularity she may have lost
among people who do not agree with her
the president has declared friday a
national holiday in defense of democracy
a united response from a government that
has seen deepening divisions over its
response to another economic crisis
which has seen 70 percent inflation some
of the highest in the world
leah harding al jazeera